good morning believe nation today's
message is just do it over to you JJ
Abrams's because the resources had been
so limited for so long there were a lot
of people who would say God if I only
had access to a camera I would make a
movie there's a lot to talk about I
remember I was in college I spend most
of my time in my room writing
screenplays really bad screenplays but I
was in my room doing that when I prize
should have been studying or something
there were a lot of people I remember at
parties who would talk about writing and
that they wanted to be writer but I
would always notice they were out every
time I would happen to go out they would
always be out and they I just know that
there are people who talk about what
they would do if but they're not
actually doing the thing and so it's a
lot easier to actually write a
screenplay than you think it is might
not be good but most people talk about
writing screenplays but don't actually
write them the people who write them
you're already like in you know the top
10 percent because you actually have
written it to achieve your goal in
business you need to think big and start
small to achieve your goal in business
you need to think big and start small be
the CEO and the janitor both too many
entrepreneurs just want to be the CEO
just want to be the visionary just want
to come up with all the ideas but you
don't want to do any of the work and you
need both you need the vision you need
the guidance you need the high level
thinking but you need to do the work the
janitor
does the work and that's what so many
entrepreneurs are missing you just want
to play in the big picture but you don't
want to actually get anything done and
if that's you then your ideas are gonna
die with you you're gonna die this
really bitter old person who always had
these big visionary ideas but never had
the team to do it never had the resource
of do or never had the support to do it
and whatever excuse do you want to throw
out there but really it's because you
didn't want to get down in the trenches
and clean the toilet you didn't want to
do the grungy grime
hustle daily in a network and at the
start you need to do the work like yes
as you get up as you build the team as
you start having success you can move
higher and higher up the chain and just
there'll be more of that visionary but
at the start when it's just you you kind
of do everything you got to hustle it
out if I look at this YouTube channel I
started doing everything in my first
video I clubbed with a friend of mine he
helped me film it but most of my videos
at the start were me me with a camera
with no lighting and no microphone and
sometimes it was wobbly and the focus
was out of you know Dayton and you know
was hard to see me me doing the editing
which was Windows Movie Maker at the
beginning very basic very simple very
plain me doing the naming me doing the
tagging me doing the promotion me doing
the background research me doing the in
front of the camera stopped me doing the
audio recording everything mean it was
me I did everything I planned everything
from a CEO level and then I did all the
work from a janitor level and as I built
it up to the point where I started
making some money
I started handing off some of those
tasks and that let me go from a video a
week to a video a day and I move closer
and closer and closer up the chain to
the point where now I'm guiding
everything I'm still the on-camera
talent right I still do this work
because I love it not only because I'm
good at it and getting better but I love
it this is what I love doing
I still review every video that goes out
and all the research behind because I
love it cuz I learned from it because I
care about the product that we're
creating but my team puts all that
together you know even this like I have
we use Evernote let me load it up you
know I use Evernote here and I've got a
list of all the topics I need to talk
about today all the topics who I'm doing
shoutouts for where the research is what
the clip is that I need to watch all of
that stuff my team puts together for me
this thing gets filmed I have Jason
behind the camera filming it for me he's
gonna send it to Christine on video
editing we've got three editors who are
gonna cut it all up post to the YouTube
channels title it descriptions tags
playlists all that stuff it goes up and
I'm guiding it from a high level
but I built it up to that point if I was
just starting out and that was my my
idea like I'm gonna do this and I'm
gonna just wait for other people to do
things for me it's not gonna happen and
so it's thinking big I love it think big
you need it because a lot of people
don't think big enough and they stay
stuck doing being a janitor for their
entire life
think big it's great but start be the
janitor too and work your way up add
more value focus on what you can add the
most value to so you can bring on people
to alleviate some of the tasks for you
and help you build closer to that big
thing that you want to do to achieve
your goal you need to think big act
small so the question today today is I
want an example task from you guys your
CEO tasks and a janitor tasks the big
and the small give one example of both
that you're currently doing today in
your business or plan to do today in
your business one CEO task one janitor
tasks write in the comments below
and will join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to Kate
Murray O'Brien Kate thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word I really appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying it thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one word is and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
[Music]
they believe nation thank you so much
for watching if you want to learn more
about this subject get a little bit
deeper on it I'm gonna share some extra
bonus clips that I hope you'll enjoy
just do it just pick up a camera and
start shooting something don't wait to
be asked because nobody's going to ask
you and don't wait for the perfect
conditions because they'll never be
perfect it's a little bit like having a
child if you wait until the right time
to have a child you'll die childless and
I think filmmaking is very much the same
thing you just have to take the plunge
and just start shooting something even
if it's bad you can always hide it but
you will have learned something it was a
lot harder to get started when I was
growing up and wanting to be a movie
director almost at 12 years old because
when I first picked up a camera in order
to get out where were you living with
you I was in Scottsdale here in Arizona
you know I got I was looking for a way
to get fulfill the requirements to get a
photography merit badge I was in the Boy
Scouts of America and the manager said
don't make her before no I don't be a
filmmaker at all I just want to be a
Eagle Scout that was my only aspiration
was become want to get the highest rank
I couldn't in this in scouting and so on
my way to being an Eagle Scout I had to
get a certain you know requisite amount
of merit badges and one of them I
wanting it was photography and the
requirement was to tell a story was
still photographs and my dad's camera
broke he did not have a still camera
like the brownie Kodak that he had
wasn't working so I but he did an
eight-millimeter Kodak eight millimeter
movie camera and I went to the
Scoutmaster and I said can we change the
rules just so I can tell a story on film
because we don't have a still camera and
the Scoutmaster said go ahead and do it
so I got three minutes worth of film
which is by the way all those cameras
used to take this little three minute
rolls of film and I made this Western on
a weekend I sure thank you how did you
edit did you camera camera cut you know
a little shot at my friends and cowboy
outfits robbing a stagecoach which was
sort of an exhibit out in front of a
place called Pinnacle Peak patio a
restaurant which is still there outside
of scotch and you know two camera K you
just I just figured out you know you do
a shot in this direction of bad guys
with their guns and masks on and my
citrus played the damsels in distress
and the stagecoach giving away their
costume jewelry well my mother's jewelry
we took my mom to give away to 12 year
olds you know pretending to be robbers
and I made this little movie and then
showed it to the Boy Scout Troop that
weekend and they all went crazy for it
they screamed and applauded and I
suddenly got bitten by that bug and I
wanted to do this for the rest of my
life it was like became so clear to me
but it was hard then because to make
movies you had to pay for film and pay
for developing in the film so I had to
go to my dad and say dad you know our
and some money but I can earn all the
money because I I go to school I can't
get a job there and the money to pay for
all this equipment so my dad helped me
however today it's easier today
everybody seems to have a camcorder
everybody has some high eight digital
camera and it's a lot easier to get your
hands on you buy that editing program
for the computer you can buy it as
software program for the computer and go
out and make a movie and tell a story
and figure out who you are as a
storyteller and and so in a sense it's
easier today for young people to at
least prove to themselves is what they
want to do for the rest of their lives
or at least in the interim of the rest
of their lives and it's also if you get
bitten by that bug you can make a lot
little movies and somehow those films
will get seen by people hopefully that
will hire you do a music video someday
or a TV commercial or a television show
or someday a feature film I was a very
headstrong young person and by 1983 or
four had started my own publishing
company to publish my own books
realizing that no one else will publish
me and I was right about that and so my
first book I saved my food money from
Black Flag a little here little there
and I saved enough to make a fold and
staple book I couldn't type so I handed
out the things and I made a dummy that I
could offset print fold and staple and I
sold them for $2 mainly gave them away
but I sold enough and they blew out 500
just went and then I took that money to
make another print run of that and from
that money I made my first paperback and
33 years later that's a fully staffed
company with books in translation and
hardcover edition
in the whole you know the whole nine
yards but it started with I'm gonna do
my thing I'll be city lights jr. without
the talent and that's I did that at the
same time I was doing my first spoken
word gigs and why did I have the
gumption and the audacity to start my
own book company because I come from
punk rock I come from watching Ian
MacKaye invent Dischord records on his
mom's kitchen table I come from folding
and gluing picture sleeves together
black-flag had their own label of course
you'd do it yourself you want to make a
book sit down and write it then go to
the printing place where's a printer get
in the phone book and find a printer we
make records make some books it was you
just do it it's like you don't even
think about you just do it and I'm sure
that writing is this awful but I did it
and without even hesitation I'm making
my own book companies stop me I dare you
I've never thought about it twice just
because DIY man like let your voice be
heard